Salut la team Mentalo! Récemment, je vous ai fait la 2ième vidéo sur le mensonge,
et vous avez été nombreux, très nombreux, quasiment tout le monde à me demander une 3ième vidéo.
Alors, là voici!
Je sais très bien que nous sommes lundi, et qu'en temps normal, c'est jour de vlog,
mais, au bénéfice de votre demande, je remplace le vlog par celle-ci.
Dans la détection des mensonges, et donc des menteurs,
nous allons nous attarder aujourd'hui sur le physique et surtout sur la gestuelle.
Si on s'attarde uniquement sur les mots, alors, le risque de "Broco" augmente.
Le risque de broco, c'est un terme, une espèce de phrase qu'a inventé Paul Ekman
sur une discussion qu'il avait eue avec un homme qui s'appelle Broco.
Et tous ceux qui ont suivi les travaux d'Ekman, comme moi, quand on dit le risque de Broco,
c'est qu'on parle du risque d'un jugement erroné.
De prendre quelqu'un pour un menteur, par exemple,  alors qu'il est juste simplement stressé.
Abordons le sujet très intéressant des lapsus emblématiques.
Avant de parler du lapsus emblématique, qu'est ce qu'un emblème?
Les emblèmes sont des gestes précis dont le sens est connu de tout le monde, toute la population,
quasiment peu importe l'âge.
Il en existe bien sûr des culturels, qui n'ont sens que dans un pays,
par exemple, en Inde, souvent, on te dit "oui" comme ça, avec un petit hochement de tête.
En Europe, on a une soixantaine de gestes qui ne nécessitent ni mot, ni contexte pour comprendre le sens de ce qu'ils veulent dire.
Par exemple, si je vous fais "oui",
"non",
"viens par là, toi",
ou encore le haussement d'épaules qui veut dire "quelle importance?",
le doigt d'honneur, vous savez très bien ce que ça veut dire.
La main au niveau de l'oreille, le pouce pour faire du stop, ...
Habituellement, sans parole, les gestes n'ont aucun sens.
Si je vous fait juste des gestes comme ça, vous ne comprendrez pas ce que je veux vous dire, c'est normal.
Alors que les emblèmes, on sait exactement ce qu'ils veulent dire.
Et là où ça devient intéressant, c'est que les emblèmes peuvent être réalisés inconsciemment.
Ca donne un lapsus emblématique, de la même manière qu'on peut avoir un lapsus verbal dans les mots.
Le lapsus emblématique, c'est également l'emblème fuité,
c'est à dire, pas l'emblème réalisé à 100%, mais en partie, et pas forcément à l'endroit où il devrait avoir lieu.
En général, les emblèmes sont faits à ce niveau-là, pour que l'interlocuteur ne puisse pas le rater.
Un emblème fuité va se déporter à un endroit où il n'aurait pas lieu d'être.
Et surtout, il ne va pas forcément être complet.
Principalement parce que, les emblèmes fuités sont réalisés inconsciemment.
Si je prend l'emblème le plus percutant, par exemple le doigt d'honneur,
ça peut être simplement quelqu'un qui est positionné comme ça.
C'est un bout de doigt d'honneur, même si il n'est pas fait complètement, même si il n'est pas à sa bonne place, il est quand même ici.
Tout le monde ne réalise pas forcément d'emblème fuité ou de lapsus emblématique.
C'est à peu près 20% de la population.
Là aussi, je me base sur les chiffres d'Ekman.
Donc vous ne détecterez pas de lapsus emblématique chez tout le monde,
par contre, quand vous en détecté un, il est 100% fiable.
Quelqu'un qui fait "non" avec la tête alors qu'il est en train de vous dire "oui",
ou l'inverse.
Une personne qui vous dit qu'elle était très impliquée dans ce qui venait de se passer,
alors que vous détectez un haussement d'épaules.
Le haussement d'épaules n'est pas un geste naturel, c'est vraiment un emblème.
Jamais, spontanément, on va faire ça.
Quelqu'un qui vous dit qu'il est très calme, qui vit bien la situation, qui n'a aucune colère en lui,
alors que vous voyez l'emblème du doigt d'honneur quelque part.
Soyez très attentif car, comme je viens de vous le dire, c'est pas systématique, par contre, c'est 100% fiable.
Ce qui nous amène sur les illustrants, qui est différents des lapsus emblématiques.
Les illustrants, c'est ce que je fais à longueur de temps dans les vidéos, c'est de vous parler un petit peu avec les mains.
Quand on discute avec quelqu'un, on symbolise par les gestes.
Sans les mots, ces gestes n'ont aucune signification.
Si vous me faites voir une vidéo de quelqu'un qui remue les mains, je ne sais pas du tout si c'est un menteur ou pas,
je ne sais même pas de quoi il veut parler.
Les illustrants ne sont pas quelque chose d'inné, on ne naît pas avec une manière de faire et de parler.
C'est un acquis, c'est à dire que ça se contrôle, que ça se maîtrise.
On peut déterminer si on fait beaucoup de mouvements ou pas.
Selon les rites sociaux, c'est plus ou moins bien vu, donc on va un petit peu jauger notre manière de parler.
Ce qui est d'abord important, c'est de déterminer le rythme d'illustrants habituel de la personne.
Est-ce qu'elle parle beaucoup en bougeant,
pas du tout, ...
Essayez de déterminer ça et vous allez pouvoir ressentir quand la personne ment,
puisque le changement d'illustrants va changer.
Et quand je dis qu'il va changer, c'est qu'il va diminuer.
La personne va beaucoup moins illustrer, pour deux raisons :
principalement parce qu'elle n'est pas impliquée émotionnellement dans ce qu'elle dit,
donc elle ne ressent pas les choses. Elle n'a pas besoin d'appuyer les choses.
Deuxièmement parce que la personne fait attention à ce qu'elle dit.
Elle est trop concentrée sur son discours et elle ne sait pas encore forcément tout ce qu'elle va dire dans son mensonge,
donc elle ne peut pas encore l'illustrer.
Récapitulatif : pour les illustrants, gérez le curseur de la personne, essayez de voir comment elle illustre en temps normal.
Et ensuite, si vous voyez une nette diminution, avec d'autres signes, c'est qu'elle ment.
Et enfin, parlons rapidement des manipulatoires, parce que je crois que cette vidéo commence à être très longue.
Les manipulatoires, c'est quand une partie de notre corps va toucher une autre partie de notre corps, voire même un objet, un accessoire.
Quand je dis "toucher", ça peut être frotter, ça peut être gratter, ça peut être simplement toucher,
ça peut être, oui, tiens, pincer comme ça, ça peut être gratter aussi.
Les zones privilégiées sont les cheveux, les oreilles, le nez, un petit peu la barbe pour les hommes,
un accessoire comme un briquet, un téléphone, un crayon qui traîne sur la table, ...
Alors, que nous disent les manipulatoires sur le mensonge?
On a souvent cru qu'une personne qui se touchait en parlant comme ça, c'était quelqu'un qui mentait systématiquement.
C'est pas vrai! C'est complètement faux.
Faux... pas complètement, pas complètement, mais ça augmente énormément le risque de Broco, c'est à dire, le risque de se tromper.
Pourquoi? Parce que les manipulatoires ressortent énormément dans des situations qui sont très opposées :
dans une situation de stress, de malaise, et dans une situation de bien être et de détente.
Donc, plus je suis mal à l'aise, plus je vais avoir de gestes manipulatoires,
et plus je vais être détendu, plus je vais avoir de gestes manipulatoires.
Je vous conseille vivement de ne pas vous fier qu'à ces gestes-là.
Ils doivent être accompagnés d'au moins 2, 3 autres validations
pour être sûr que la personne qui est en face de vous est en train de mentir.
Vous me l'aviez demandée et vous l'avez eue. C'était donc la 3ième vidéo sur le mensonge.
Peut-être que j'en ferai une 4ième voire une 5ième dans l'année, mais pas avant, je dirais, octobre.
Puisque là, ça en fait déjà 3. Ou septembre, si vous me le demandez.
Si vous avez une anecdote marrante à raconter sur quelqu'un qui a menti et que vous avez grillé,
je serais très très heureux de lire ça dans les commentaires.
Ca peut être drôle! Si vous avez un jour cramé un menteur et que ça a été assez drôle pour être raconté,
vous nous le mettez dans les commentaires.
Merci beaucoup d'avoir regardé cette vidéo. Si ça vous a plu, n'hésitez pas à me le faire savoir en laissant un sincère et honnête...
pouce en l'air!
Et n'oubliez pas de faire tourner cette vidéo et de vous abonner à la chaîne avant de partir,
puisque le mental vlog, c'est une vidéo par jour, pendant un an, donc rendez-vous demain à 17h! Ciao!